Pour ne louper aucune vidéo,
abonnez-vouset activez la petite cloche !
Bonjour les Épicurieuses et les Épicurieux.
Savez-vouspourquoi nous qualifions une personne
que l'on trouve un peu stupide
de " courge " ou de " têtede courge " ?
En latin,
courge se dit " Cucurbita ".
A l'époque,
les romains utilisaientdéjà
des ventouses pour se soigner.
C'est certainement l'instrument de médecine
leplus ancien connu à ce jour,
qu'ils avaient baptisé
ventosa
cucurbita.
Comme cette ventouse servait à aspirer,
cette expression a fini par désigner,
de manière péjorative,
une têtevide.
Ventosa
cucurbita
fut transformé en cucurbitae Caput.
Littéralement
" tête de courge ! ".
Mêmesi l'intérieur d'une courge
est loin d'être vide.
Pas sûr ?